Kylie Jenner flaunts her famous curves  in a new sexy shoot a GQ Germany this is  Kylie Jenner and I hope you guys love my  August cover  [Music]  the 19 year old turned up the heat in  her new GQ Germany spread posing in a  revealing bikini that put her cleavage  under boob and toned tummy on full  display  the reality star rocked the nude  two-piece for several shots covered  herself up with a bedsheet for another  steamy picked posed in bed for this  sultry moment and sported this one-piece  complete with a sheer cover-up the teen  is gearing up for the August 6 debut of  her keeping up with the kardashians  spin-off series life of Kylie there's an  image that I feel constantly pressure to  keep up with and then there's who I  really am that's who I want you guys to  get to know and she tells the mag her  new show is more intimate than the  family reality show quote I can finally  show everything all sides of me and who  I really am  for me it feels like therapy  [Music]